an octopus chair and Where's Waldo
oh he's on this guy's back forever
Vsauce Kevin here this is mine walk-ins
inkling is a digital sketchpad that uses
a digitized pen to capture and transfer
your sketches into vector images you can
create layers with it attach it to any
notepad and then just connect it to your
computer that's for technology in the
morbid Department there's the body
liquefaction unit it's an
environmentally friendly alternative to
cremation that dissolves the body in
heated alkaline water okay no pump tire
self inflates as you ride your bike it's
just a prototype right now but the idea
is that the force of the tire on the
road pushes air into it until the
desired pressure is filled to fill your
wetsuit with air and potentially save
your life check out Billabong's
v1 wetsuit it incorporates an inflatable
bladder that acts as an emergency
flotation device for surfers who wipeout
and in case you were wondering what's
soaring in a wingsuit looks like jeb
Corliss decided to show us
seedy in a microwave the world's biggest
swing is in Queenstown New Zealand it
has a 300 meter arc with a 70 meter
freefall and it lets you swing forward
backwards tandem and uh astronomers
found a planet that they think is made
up of crystallized carbon otherwise
known as diamond and Cornell found out
what it's like when two clever BOTS
talked to each other here's a bit of
their artificially intelligent
conversation together they're robots
I'm not a robot I'm a unicorn but you
said earlier that you were a robot I
didn't know I thought you did melting
crayon time-lapse finally here's a 3d
handheld from the 80s taken apart and
turned into a music video using sound
samples from the game
I'm gonna leave you with an announcement
the mind-blower itll is going to be
retired so real fans stay tuned for a
brand-new episode of 5 4 3 2 1 next week
for your riddle challenge now there are
three clues in the description of this
video and one at facebook.com slash
vsauce gaming the first person to answer
all four correctly will be our genius of
the week so good luck and as always
thanks for watching